ahora lo que vamos a hacer es escribir
12.98 como una fracción y bueno el
principal truco que hay que hacer en
estos casos es notar que este número es
igual a 12 un entero + 0.98 un decimal o
sea estamos dividiendo el número en su
parte entera y su parte decimal y bueno
su parte entera ya está escrita como
fracción ya es 12 entre 1 pero
generalmente nos gusta dejarlo en
notación de enteros por otro lado este
número decimal lo que nos está diciendo
es que tenemos un 9 en el lugar de las
décimas y eso lo que significa es que
hay 9 décimas o sea 9 entre 10 y tenemos
18 en el lugar de las centésimas o sea
tenemos un 8 entre 100 y ya este número
es tal cual 9 entre 10 más 8 entre 100 y
bueno ya que estamos haciendo una suma
de fracciones lo primero que tenemos que
hacer es encontrar un denominador común
aquí está muy fácil porque 10 por 10 100
y ahora si como multiplicamos por 10 el
denominador tenemos que multiplicar por
10 el numerador entonces aquí nos quedan
90 más y aquí tenemos tal cual lo que
teníamos 8 centésimas y hacer la suma
así es súper sencillo tenemos 98
centésimas ok
aquí podríamos tratar de convertir este
12 en centésimas también pero no vale la
pena porque muchas veces nos gusta dejar
la anotación separada entre los enteros
y los decimales y ese va a ser el caso
en este momento entonces lo que tenemos
son 12 más 98 centésimas pero esta
fracción se puede simplificar y siempre
que se pueda simplificar hay que hacerlo
saber este es un número par y éste
también no
o sea que el 2 divide a ambos números
así es que vamos a dividirlo entre 2
dividir entre 2 numerador y denominador
y esto lo que nos queda es 98 entre 2
haber 90 entre 2 son 45 1 y 8 entre 2
son 4
entonces 45 449
y si entre 250 entonces lo que tenemos
son 12 unas 49 50 vos 12.98 se ve así
cuando lo escribimos como una fracción